au bout de
[Musique]
la
je vais te rallumer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci à tous de nous avoir suivis sur C8
bravo Afida Turner pour cette jolie live
et oui et oui
aujourd'hui sur C8 on aime les artistes
de ce qu'on va dire elle fait son truc
en plus je la trouve hyper drôle elle
sait qu'elle est drôle hein
il faut qu'elle vienne parce que là elle
est partie là
mais elle va revenir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sur la tête de ma mère que je vais
l'amener à la barre de mon fils c'est
incroyable franchement elle qui fait
Étienne
non non Afida Turner c'est elle est
mythique j'adore mais la CADA c'est que
on a l'impression qu'elle danse devant
5000 personnes et qu'elle chante en fait
il y a Jordan Deluxe qui est au bout de
sa vie
le gars était ma Jordan frère mais mais
je le sens quand même un peu kiffé
non mais alors
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est pas gênant pour vous
c'est pas en manger non de télé
je suis désolé de te dire ça mais c'est
notre Madonna à la française
moi je suis d'accord moi je suis
complètement d'accord avec toi